There is a pastor in Baltimore.
His name is Michael Phillips,
he is the pastor of Kingdom Life Church,
and he often talks about how problems
show up in our lives so arrogantly,
with so much confidence, as if there is
just nothing we can do about them.
And the murder rate in Baltimore
had been doing that.
Year after year, it just
kept showing up as this big thing
that there was nothing any of us
could do anything about.
But the thing about Baltimore
is that it has never been the one
to just be defeated.
So the story about the Baltimore Ceasefire
is that Baltimore looked
the murder rate in the eye
and said, "What you're not going to do
is snatch our greatness."
So two years ago,
I'm at a 300 Man March meeting.
At the time, I was a leader
in that movement.
And this guy named Ogun --
he's like a godfather
of hip-hop in Baltimore --
he came over to me and he said,
"Yo, I have this idea about
calling a ceasefire in Baltimore,
and I feel like you are somebody
I should talk to about that."
And I was like, "I'm absolutely
somebody you should talk to about that,
because that's something we should do."
And so we played phone tag
and meeting tag,
and two years went by and we never
really sat down and talked about it.
So now we're in May of 2017.
My son Paul, he's 19 years old,
he's driving me home from work one day,
and he says, "Ma, did you know
that the murder rate in Baltimore
is higher than it's ever been?"
And I said, "What you mean
it's higher than it's ever been?
How is that possible?
Like, I mean, what about people who say
they have connections to the streets?
Why won't they use those connections
and call a cease-fire or something?"
And on and on I went
from my own feelings of helplessness
about what other people weren't doing.
The next morning I woke up
and I realized that what I was
really angry about
wasn't about what other people
weren't doing,
it was that I had heard
this message years ago,
and I hadn't moved on it.
So it was about what I
was supposed to be doing.
So I got up and I'm going,
"OK, if we could
just have three days
where everybody in the city
was committing,
nobody is going to kill anybody,
and we're going to celebrate life instead,
when can we do that?"
So it's May, I look at my calendar,
all right, I've got some free time
the first weekend in August,
we'll do it August 4th
through August 6th, right?
So I'm all excited,
I start driving to work,
and the more I drive, the scareder I get.
And so I start going, "Never mind ...
(Laughter)
I won't say this thing out loud.
Nobody will ever know
I was thinking it if I don't say it."
But it wouldn't let me go,
because God loves to show up as us,
and because I look broken
and I'm always called
to stand in my wholeness,
there was a call on my life
to say this thing out loud.
And because my city looks broken
and is always yearning
to show up in its wholeness,
there were hearts that morning
calling all through my chest
that people around this city
wanted to do something great together.
And people who had already
been killed in my city
were calling to me
up through my gut and my chest,
as a knot in my throat, "Yo, E,
you cannot just let us be dead in vain
when you know how to say
this thing out loud."
And I responded to them with my fear.
"But somebody might get killed
anyway that weekend."
And that was the moment
where I had to accept
that maybe while we're out
spreading this message --
"Hey, nobody's going to kill anybody.
We're going to celebrate life!" --
maybe somebody will be plotting
to take a life right then and there,
but now they would have
a rumbling in their spirit.
And so I knew it was time for my city
to have a collective
rumbling in our spirit.
So I got on the phone, got around to Ogun,
and I said, "Yo, you said
you wanted to do a cease-fire?
What is it? I'm ready."
So he said, "You know, when I hear about
the Israelis and Palestinians at war,
I'm like, that's too bad,
they should stop that,
but when I hear the word 'cease-fire,'
that makes me pause and stop
and really research what's going on."
And he wanted Baltimore
to get that same kind of attention
from the outside,
but introspection from the inside
about what was going on with us.
And we talked about how it couldn't
belong to one person.
Not one person or one organization
should call a cease-fire.
The whole city had to own it
and do it together.
So we had our first meeting in May.
About 12 or 15 people show up,
and this is where it gets named
the Baltimore Ceasefire,
because you know what that means
when you hear the word "cease-fire."
Just don't kill nobody.
And this is where the Baltimore
Peace Challenge was born.
Because it's not just about
not being violent.
It is about being purposefully peaceful.
What is going on in your thoughts?
What kind of petty things
are you not saying out of your mouth?
How are you responding
in your behaviors to conflict?
I grabbed up five people who I trusted,
and the six of us became
the organizing squad.
So let's give them props real quick.
On the count of three,
I want you to yell "squad."
One, two, three: squad! Audience: Squad!
And it's Shellers's birthday.
Happy birthday, Shellers.
Audience: Happy birthday!
And so we put out a press release,
and the media told us,
this is not really a story yet,
we will get with you on August 7th
to see how the cease-fire went.
So we went, "Oh, word?
Oh, all right then."
And Baltimore got to work,
and not only did people send money
to the PayPal account
so we could buy flyers and posters,
people came and got the flyers and posters
and they put them all around the city,
and people were having
conversations with each other.
What kind of resources do you need?
What are you going through?
What has happened to you?
Because we understand the root causes
of violence in this country.
People who said it wouldn't work
still ended their sentence
with "but please keep trying.
Somebody needs to do something anyway."
Teenagers who would tell us
about the stuff they were doing
in the streets all day asked,
"But can I have a poster
to put it on my wall at night
so I can see it on my way to bed?"
Gangsters were calling, saying,
"I can tell you where
violence is not going to come from,
because we're committing
to the Peace Challenge."
And they kept their word.
When people said, "It's not going to work,
because somebody's going to kill
over West or over East,"
we said, "That doesn't matter.
It's about self-determination, yo.
You telling me you can't keep
this three- or six-block radius safe?"
And they would say, "Don't get it twisted.
It's going to stay safe around here."
And they kept their promise.
(Applause)
Four songs --
and I know it looks like
I'm holding up five fingers,
but I have four fingers,
so this is four for me --
four songs got made
about the Baltimore Ceasefire,
and the one that most exemplifies it,
where a bunch of artists
came together and made a song,
that one is currently nominated
for a Grammy out here. Right?
And so now what was happening
was from the most beautiful
corners of crack houses
to the grimiest corners
of politicians' offices,
everybody --
(Laughter)
was talking about this thing
Baltimore was doing together. Right?
And then, the weekend came:
events all over the city,
people yelling "Happy Ceasefire Day!"
Over 200 people got their records
expunged and got jobs,
and people went
into drug recovery programs
because of what was happening
in our city that weekend.
People were going, "But the air
feels different in Baltimore.
Nobody's mother
got that phone call last night.
I didn't hear any gunshots."
And on Saturday, Trey went to go get a job
and was excited about it.
At 24 hours of no killing,
we were singing Kendrick Lamar.
"We gon' be alright. We gon' be alright."
And then at 4:59 on Saturday,
we get a message that somebody was killed.
We didn't know his name,
but it turned out to be Trey.
So we rushed over to Sargeant Street,
and we held hands in a circle
and we looked at the pavement,
and we said, "This is sacred ground
because we make it so,
because everywhere in our city
where people lose their lives to violence
needs to be sacred ground."
And it wasn't just about
upholding Trey and his transition
and sending love to his family.
It was about us pausing to really
think about what must it feel like
20 minutes after you kill somebody?
Can't we pour love into that?
Because until we do,
we will not heal this epidemic.
Later on in the day, we get another call.
Dante is murdered.
So by the end of this day, we were shook.
In real life, we were shook,
because we had opened up
our hearts together
and changed the atmosphere of this city,
and now our hearts were broken together.
And we had to be honest
about the fact that last weekend,
when we lost six people to violence,
it didn't feel the way it felt
this weekend when we lost these two,
because now we were paying attention.
Now we were all hoping together
that nobody got killed.
And so we had to make a vow with ourselves
not to be numb anymore
when we lose people in our city.
These two lives were going to remind us
to vibrate higher and to move forward.
So as we move forward
into Baltimore Ceasefire 365,
because there's work that needs
to be done all year,
and there's another cease-fire
happening next weekend,
November 3rd through 5th.
Mark your calendar.
(Applause)
Right? And we expect the same thing.
It was news media
from all around the world,
Australia and Norway and China.
Everybody wanted to come
get this work from Baltimore,
and y'all could come get it. Right?
So as we push forward,
we don't need to keep asking now
"What can we do?"
We have seen the power
of collective consciousness.
Y'all were the ones
who misunderstood Baltimore.
Y'all thought Baltimore
was just "The Wire."
When we lost Freddie Gray,
y'all saw the Baltimore uprising,
and people around this world
mischaracterized it and misunderstood it.
What you failed to realize
is Baltimore is the power to rise up,
and that is what we continue to do.
(Applause)
And so as we move forward,
we see you, America,
with your systems of violent oppression
trying to beat us into the ground,
and still, we rise.
We rise and stand with cities
all over this country just like us
who are handed,
through no fault of their own,
criminal conditions in which to live,
and then they get labeled savages
for how they live.
We stand with them.
We remind them we are an example
of what you can do when you say,
"No, I don't have to accept
these conditions
that you are trying to hand me.
I get to decide what the greatest
vision of myself looks like.
And so the next time
you are faced with a dilemma,
with a problem,
you can say, "Let me be like Baltimore,
let me look it in the face,
let me tell it."
But what you're not going to do
is snatch my greatness.
Please believe it.
Thank you.
(Applause)